US President Donald Trump says the
United States could respond militarily
to the attacks on Saudi Arabian oil
facilities to drone attacks hitting the
object' facility the largest of its kind
and the caress oilfield that's the
country's second-biggest now Washington
has blamed Iran President Trump tweeting
there's reason to believe that we know
the culprit we are locked and loaded
depending on verification but are
waiting to hear from the kingdom
referring to Saudi Arabia Iranian backed
Houthi rebels based in Yemen have
claimed responsibility but the US says
there is no evidence the attacks were
logged from there for his part Iran's
president Hassan rouhani had this to say
on Roma Americans instead of confessing
that their presence in the region in
Syria and other areas has been
problematic they accuse the countries of
the region now DWS Oliver sallet has
this from Washington about the
discussion in the US Capitol about how
to respond to the attacks President
Trump's Twitter threat is causing
confusion the Pentagon reportedly urging
restraint and observers actually
believed the firing of hawkish Security
Advisor John Bolton would pave the way
for a more conciliatory tone now
president Trump's tweet ratcheting up
tensions with Iran once again his plans
of negotiating with Iran's President
rouhani are becoming more unrealistic
while a new war is clearly not in the
president's interest it also becomes
obvious that the u.s. is lacking a
strategy on the Middle East and that
puts both countries in a dangerous
position so how are the markets
responding to the loss of 5% of global
daily oil production Monica Jones from
DW business is here for more on that
good morning Monica oil price is spiking
right away on the news what's it looking
like right now
they've East somewhat I think you
mentioned it also I've just checked just
before I came to the studio currently
Brent crude Stan said sixty-seven
dollars a barrel there's still ten
percent higher than it was before they
attack but it's somewhat east and I mean
we're not surprised of course that oil
prices spiked those attacks were hitting
the world's biggest petroleum processing
facility and Saudi Arabia of course
being the biggest oil exporter shipping
more than seven million barrels a day a
knock out of five percent of global oil
supply crude supply is dramatic at least
at first especially in consider that the
facility will not be operational for
weeks to come according to experts and
this represents 50 percent of overall
Saudi oil production so so it is quite
quite a blow and it shows you know just
how vulnerable our global oil it's all
connected it's not just vulnerable I
think it's very important to say that
it's very volatile let me just remind
you is that we've been talking for weeks
and months about falling oil prices in
fact they were falling below $60 a
barrel in in recent weeks to the point
that only last week on Thursday OPEC
members came together in Saudi Arabian
particular demanded that everybody
sticks to cutting output in order to
keep prices somewhat okay especially
after it seemed on Wednesday last week
when he was present on a Trump sort of
implied that he might ease sanctions on
Iran which would have boosted output and
obviously way on prices so we're talking
about a very volatile situation but not
that dramatic yet the situation in Saudi
Arabia what happened is dramatic but
when it comes to oil prices the peaks
this year we've seen were $75 a barrel
we're not there yet were much much lower
right now okay where are we are we at
the 60 67 67 dollars a barrel barrel
there's just what we having right now
right now okay what about consumers I
mean when I Drive up to the pump you
know later today am I going to feel this
immediately I don't know if you can feel
it immediately here in Germany just yet
of course whenever something happens
with the oil price eventually it'll hit
consumer but it's quite interesting that
I found out of all it'll be the
motorists on the u.s. west coast who are
most likely to feel it why because all
facilities those that were attacked
account for nearly half of all US crude
imports from Saudi Arabia and California
in particular relies very heavily on
those imports due to lack of pipelines
to connect them with all which Texas so
there's this is a problem for you so the
Sun doesn't always shine no in
California so when it comes to problems
like this Monica thank you very much
okay